la première bataille ces deux logiques
tout le monde dignement
je ne veux plus d'ici la fin de l'année
à voir des femmes et des hommes dans les
rues dans les bois ont perdu c'est une
question de dignité c'est une question
d'humanité et d'efficacité là aussi de
belles paroles mais les actes manque
trois ans après des personnes sans
domicile fixe il y en a toujours autant
150 milles sur tout le territoire
d'après l'insee si les conditions de vie
des sdf sont difficiles en temps normal
elles le sont encore un peu plus en
cette période de confinement est d
accueil de jour ont fermé certaines
maraudes sont suspendus ainsi que des
services de distribution alimentaire
anthony 30 ans sdf depuis quatre ans
témoigne hélas les coronavirus là il ya
des dangers pour tous nous et nous c'est
les prémunit nous clinique toute l'année
de à tour devrait avoir une solution
proposition ni dette on irait même du
centre est ce qu'on appellerait pour
remédier au manque de places
d'hébergement
la mairie de paris a mise à disposition
14 gymnase pour l'accueil des sans abri
mais anthony et d'autres refusent de s'y
rendre
il estime en effet qu'il s'agit de
foyers de contamination potentielle
au début j'ai réussi à trouver vite à
une place mais là avec le secours nous
dirigerons c'est compliqué ils ont fait
une
le gymnase est en fait c'est servir la
mort puisqu'ils étaient aux cas de
corona virus par rapport au fait qu'ils
ont regroupé les gens 108,5 moi je vous
dis que c'est mieux encore dehors avec
mon duvet 20 ans que pour les sdf c'est
parfois la double peine
faute d'hébergement certains d'entre eux
ont été verbalisés pour non-respect du
confinement
une situation ubuesque dénoncée par
plusieurs associations la trace d'une
cruauté de la part de ceux qui vont
délivrer ces amendes sert police
nationale police municipale est encore
plus de ceux qui ont donné les ordres
qu'ils disent à ses agents et bien
dressées dans des contraventions pour
qu'on s'en débarrasse
parce que on sait que au bout de la
quatrième à mende c'est la
correctionnelle est donc là le risque de
prison c'est inadmissible
c'est inadmissible le gouvernement a peu
reculer sur cette question et
semble-t-il va donner ou à donner des
instructions aux préfets
on attend des éléments concrets en
croire jean baptiste eyraud fils est
possible de loger tous les sans abri
trois millions de logements sont en
effet vacants sur tout le territoire
on a aussi 3,1 millions de logements
vacants un record historique sur
l'ensemble du pays y compris les dom tom
neuf cent mille de plus qu il y a dix
ans et l'état ne réquisitionne pas de
gaulle l'a fait en 1945 pour les
prisonniers de guerre les déporter les
familles à la rue en 1962 pour les
retours des rapatriés d'algérie chirac
l'a fait en 1995 après l'occupation de
la rue du dragon qui a réquisitionné
plus de 1200 logements à paris ont très
proche banlieue par tenant à des groupes
financiers
pourquoi le gouvernement aujourd'hui ne
le fait pas à ce jour plus d'un millier
de sdf sont atteints du coc vide 19
d'après le ministre du logement tout ce
sont prises en charge dans 40 centres
d'hébergement médicalisé partout en
france